hey folks Carolyn Pettit here and I'm
going by Kevin vanora our resident
assassin's creed enthusiasts Kevin
Ubisoft today released a trailer for the
next Assassin's Creed game but it's
really a teaser in the most teasing
sense of the word it's so short it
doesn't really give us a whole lot of
information but what do you make of it
well it looks like kotaku might have
forced Ubisoft hand in this regard with
some leaked screenshots that they
published so Ubisoft put out this
trailer that doesn't tell us a whole lot
but it does tell us a little bit it
tells us that this is French Revolution
it tells us that this is Paris yes and
it tells us a name process and Creed
unity unity right um yeah and so we get
a few glimpses of the game's protagonist
in this trailer a little bit rumor the
rumor is that his name is our No yeah
but we don't know a whole lot about this
guy aside if we go by the trailer it's
just a bunch of establishing shots and
then a shot of the side of this
protagonist he's putting something in
his pocket or something aside what that
is I don't know I sort of in my head I
sort of think of it as a as a pocket
watch but I don't even know if that was
a thing in the French Revolution so the
this is this is how bad I am in history
folks but yeah I think but we can
combine what the trailer taught us with
some other rumors that have been
floating around and maybe a little bit
of speculation from our own think brains
one of which is the title itself call
the unity what we've seen by the trailer
is that Assassin's Creed unity is only
for pc xbox one and playstation 4 the
next gen starts here yeah so the rumor
is that there is going to be a different
Assassin's Creed game released for the
playstation 3 and the xbox 360 although
we don't know what that game might be
called or maybe it will be called the
same thing but be a different game we
don't necessarily know that yet saw some
speculation on my twitter feed that
perhaps the next gen version will
somehow be online and we'll have some
kind of important online feature to
bring it
to speed with Ubisoft's other games like
the crew and watchdogs and the division
and so forth I don't know exactly what
that would be like but I don't imagine
that it would be suddenly we're in a
world with a whole bunch of other people
sprinting through it as assassins but it
would be interesting to see like maybe
an overall metagame charm sort of like
the assassins that you sent out into the
world in previous Assassin's Creed games
being an online feature rather than an
offline feature now the screenshots that
we're late may have hinted at some
mechanical differences in terms of the
gameplay of how how the protagonist is
controlled indeed there there buttons
for parkour up and parkour down listed
at the top right and elite screenshots
and what they mean we don't necessarily
know yet though a few smart people in
the game spot offices suggested that
maybe that means as you leap over a
particular object maybe that means that
you will go above and em bleep up words
and then maybe you'll go downwards if
you choose to parkour down so giving you
more control over how you interact with
the environment arresting one of the
problems with Assassin's Creed you know
won't be ongoing problems is when it's
making up its mind as to where you're
going to go it doesn't always choose
exactly what you want to do when you all
too often stand allege doing this a lot
of the time and not everybody wants that
now so it'll be interesting to see what
these weak screens do or do not mean
share um in the meanwhile all we can do
is speculate in the listing trailer it
doesn't really tell us much of it no it
doesn't but I'm sure we'll be finding
out a lot more about Assassin's Creed
unity in the weeks and months ahead yeah
Kevin thanks for joining us as stay
tuned to gamespot for more on Assassin's
Creed unity
you